[Musica]
Che cosa lega una disputa tra pastore
contadini Nigeria e una barca Largo
delle nostre coste c'è una relazione tra
l'invasione russa dell'Ucraina e una
persona che decide di smettere di andare
al lavoro in automobile e c'è un nesso
tra queste cose il futuro delle nostre
città Io credo di sì ma per farlo
dobbiamo guardare Alle crepe del nostro
tempo in modo diverso ancora crepe
discuteremo di del motivo per il quale
Queste sono fondamentali guarderemo Il
filo rosso che lega quelle degli
individui quelle delle nostre comunità e
quelle della storia per cercare di
capire anche come arrivare in una
soluzione e vi chiedo di farlo insieme
perché avrò bisogno del vostro aiuto
Ma andiamo con ordine partiamo dagli
Individui e vi chiedo un po' di pazienza
se parlerò di me
La crema che ha prodotto delle decisioni
tra le più importanti nella mia vita è
quella che è sempre tra me e la mia
comunità
oggi lavori in diplomazia e mi capita di
viaggiare molto ma il viaggio più
importante della mia vita l'ho fatto
partendo da questo posto dalla stazione
treni di Messina il settembre del 2006
fino a quel momento ero convinto che era
passata la maggior parte della mia vita
non lontano da dove sono nato Dopotutto
ero e sono ancora legato come molti di
noi alla mia famiglia in effetti e ai
miei luoghi ma una rapida serie di
eventi mi ha fatto cambiare idea da
ragazzo avevo conosciuto il lato meno
nobile della nostra politica Abbiamo
trovato una certa reticenza a discutere
come alcuni grandi temi ci impattassero
direttamente e più In generale faticavo
a trovare dei canali per approcciare
queste questioni in maniera pragmatica
con progettualità e che mi permettesse
di sudarci sopra con altre persone
questo bisogno era forse più importante
in quel particolare momento storico era
il momento della maturazione politica
della mia generazione dopo Il G8 di
Genova e le tentate le torri gemelle di
New York e l'invasione dell'Iraq due
anni dopo e in quel contesto che si è
aperta la mia crepa individuale e
andiamo alle comunità
in quel momento tutta la mia generazione
faceva una certa fatica impegnarsi su
questi grandi temi rispetto alla
narrazione collettiva che è un po'
parlavai con il mondo che quasi non
c'era più le risposte che venivano dalla
politica erano anche ancora legate a
delle categorie che non riusciva a
interpretare quella particolare cesura
storica stava crescendo la distanza fra
noi e quella società ora in effetti non
era molto semplice Interpretare quel
passaggio storico se riguardiamo
indietro sembra di parlare di un'altra
epoca
dopo 24 anni di sudore e finali l'Italia
vinceva di nuovo la Coppa del Mondo
Fabio grosso Era diventato un eroe
nazionale il World economic forum uno
dei principali luoghi di discussione
dell'economia mondiale si riuniva In un
clima relativamente ottimistico
Guardando ancora alla crescita
strepitosa della Cina e dell'India
l'Unione Europea era passata da 15 a 25
paesi è un fenomeno come la brexit
sembra la pura fantascienza non si
parlava ancora tanto di cambiamento
climatico
E questa cosa rimaneva per lo più
appannaggio delle comunità scientifiche
Tuttavia in quel passaggio si percepiva
già che lo scollamento della mia
generazione presagiva qualcosa di
diverso Avvenire
nei cinque anni successivi il nostro
mondo è stato travolto da una
successione di crisi economica e
finanziaria che hanno cambiato il volto
del nostro mondo in quel momento in
Italia lo scivolamento del PIL
corrisponde all'aumento della povertà
assoluta una pressione diretta sulla
spesa sociale e sull'impiego
la crisi consiste Appunto nel fatto che
il vecchio muore è il nuovo non può
nascere diceva Gramsci e in quella fase
la crisi può effettivamente un freno per
una generazione intera
se pensiamo per esempio alla città di
Messina soprattutto al sud pensiamo alla
città di Messina nei 15 anni dopo la
crisi sono andati via oltre 20.000
persone soprattutto giovani in età
lavorativa sono numeri da guerra
Ma la crisi ha avuto anche un altro
effetto più difficile da identificare ma
dalle conseguenze molto profonde la
crisi ha avvicinato il nostro Orizzonte
ci ha costretto all'urgente al qui e ora
a scapito del domani
e questo ha delle conseguenze profonde
prendiamo per esempio ancora messine
tutta la Sicilia Terre di frontiera e
migrazioni da quando esiste la civiltà
per tutti gli anni della cosiddetta
crisi migratoria i nostri territori si
sono occupati su come sostanzialmente a
gestire gli sbarchi e non guardare alle
cause profonde che spingono a questi
viaggi della disperazione anche per
trovare dei modi per gestire un fenomeno
millenario come le migrazioni
ma se guardiamo al nostro passato non è
stato sempre così e possiamo ritrovare
degli esempi in cui proprio quando
abbiamo spinto l'orizzonte in avanti
abbiamo portato le nostre società avanti
Di conseguenza restiamo ancora su
Messina
3 casi dal nostro passato 1 primo
settembre 1847 e proprio da Messina che
partirono alcune dei più importanti
motorivoluzionari di metà 800 la
frattura di Messina ha aperto una crepa
nel controllo della monarchia borbonica
che si faceva via via più repressiva e
quando questa contagiò Palermo Messina
Fu uno dei fronti principali ora questa
è anche una storia di grande sacrificio
ma senza quel gesto senza i moduli
risorgimentali avremmo continuato a
vivere sotto la stessa depressione
1955 l'Europa sta ripartendo dalle
macerie della seconda guerra mondiale in
quel contesto sotto il peso di milioni
di vittime sembrava impensabile che
francese e tedeschi italiani e Belgio
lussemburghesi olandesi mettessero da
parte secoli di guerre e violenze per
lanciare un progetto di Cooperazione
pacificazione a tratti utopistico ma è
proprio Nel giugno del 55 a Messina che
si gettano le basi della Comunità
Europea dell'energia atomica e di quello
che due anni dopo sarebbe stato
conosciuto come mercato come europeo
sono le fondamenta dell'Unione Europea
che abbiamo ritirato noi oggi nata anche
per l'insistenza del messinese Gaetano
Martino che aveva raccolto l'entusiasmo
della città di Messina dei messinesi per
gli ideali e valori dei Padri fondatori
dell'Unione Europea
la terza storia non avviene a Messina ma
a New York per le mani di un illustre
messinese
1998 Ambasciatore Francesco Paolo Fulci
il nostro più importante diplomatico
alle Nazioni Unite iniziano ad emergere
dei progetti di riforma del consiglio di
sicurezza il suo Organo più importante
per misurarsi col potere dei membri
permanenti del consiglio Stati Uniti
Cina Russia Francia e Gran Bretagna
l'ambasciatore Fuji si fa portatore di
una visione volta ad allargare in parte
democratizzare il consiglio di sicurezza
a parte tecnicismi questa è ancora oggi
una delle Correnti principali per la
riforma delle Nazioni e della nostra
governance globale
ora questi tre casi non devono esserci
di conforto ma servono a ricordarci come
c'è stata una moltitudine di comunità di
gruppi e di individui che hanno spostato
l'orizzonte in avanti anche partendo da
una definizione dei bisogni delle
proprie comunità
e qui arriviamo alla terza al terzo
livello alla terza frattura che è quella
del tornante della storia che stiamo
attraversando oggi le grandi crisi del
nostro tempo ci impongono di guardare
alle conseguenze dei grandi fenomeni
globali prendiamo le più importanti di
questi anni 1 la pandemia un virus si
propaga a tutti gli angoli del mondo con
conseguenze fatali la pandemia ci ha
ricordato che l'interdipendenza anche
degli effetti negativi e quando non
fatali questa ha il potere di mettere di
tenere le nostre vite sotto Scacco di
mettere a repentaglio il nostro sistema
di convivenza e di cambiare le nostre
priorità
2 il clima abbiamo appena chiuso Il
decennio più caldo da quando registriamo
le temperature mondiali da sempre la
crisi climatica è la nostra vera urgenza
e dobbiamo immediatamente cambiare il
nostro sistema produttivo per passare a
un'organizzazione che ci permette di
avere un impatto Zero sostanzialmente e
non possiamo più perdere tempo terzo la
guerra
invasione russa dell'Ucraina ha causato
gravissime sofferenze trascini ha
provocato una delle più macroscopiche
violazioni del diritto internazionale
e anche sovvertito l'ordine di sicurezza
europeo Facendoci svegliare in un
continente molto più sicuro
Ho preso queste foto a brodo di Anca a
50 km a ovest di Kiev
Come possiamo misurarci con una potenza
che non si fa scrupoli ad utilizzare la
forza per avanzare i propri obiettivi di
politica estera
possiamo sovvertire anzi possiamo
costruire la pace senza sovvertire i
rapporti di forza in questo conflitto e
soprattutto possiamo continuare a dare
assoluta priorità alle nostre
preoccupazioni domestiche quando anche
noi ne sentiamo le conseguenze dirette
in termini di sicurezza di energia di
costo del cibo e delle materie prime
la risposta ovviamente è no E questa è
la crepa che si apre a livello globale
ora Dopo tutta questa successione di
fatti Allegri mi sembrerà strano che io
stia per dire una cosa del genere Io
credo che tutte queste crisi ci
consegnano invece uno scenario in cui
possiamo ricominciare a essere ottimisti
tutte queste crisi che mostrano come
dobbiamo impegnarci sulle conseguenze
profonde sulle cause usate sulle cause
profonde e non sulle conseguenze di
questi fenomeni ci dimostra che le
piccole toppe di urgenza non sono
sufficienti ci impongono di ricominciare
a progettare
Neverland
Non sprecare Mai una buona crisi diceva
Churchill e non lo dobbiamo fare io
penso anche sfruttando il massimo della
nostra creatività ai momenti difficili
ora dal mio punto di vista oltre la
crisi climatica per la quale mi auguro
non servano ulteriori incoraggiamenti
voglio segnalare tre cose
la prima ancora la guerra oltre
l'invasione russa dell'Ucraina Sì c'era
un problema altrettanto grande il numero
di morti per violenza organizzata
nell'anno precedente L'invasione è stato
di 120.000 in un anno il 46% superiore
all'anno precedente
per 5 anni ho lavorato all'interno
che si occupa di prevenzione dei
conflitti Allora ripetevo spesso
prevenire una crisi è molto più
efficiente che doveva gestire quando la
violenza esplosa sia perché costa un
numero inferiore di vite sia perché
costa di meno
Ma le priorità dei governi le urgenze in
certi momenti legate soprattutto a
priorità domestiche non consentono di
lavorare a questo
a questo approccio la prevenzione dei
conflitti in maniera sempre efficiente a
volte era anche una questione di avere
in senso comune tra di noi la percezione
Chiara del rischio prendono un esempio
nel 2016 il cosiddetto stato islamico
controllava la città di Sirte in Libia
si trova alla stessa distanza dalla
Sicilia che ci divide dalla Toscana
ora capite che soprattutto dopo
l'invasione russa dell'Ucraina non
abbiamo più alibi la prevenzione dei
conflitti è uno dei più grandi
investimenti che possiamo fare sul
nostro futuro
secondo il baricentro del potere
mondiale si sposta sempre più a oriente
grazie alla continua accesa della Cina
questo fenomeno Ci obbliga a rispondere
urgentemente ad alcune domande
soprattutto se vogliamo che il domani
somigli un po' di più alla versione
ideale che abbiamo in mente come porci
davanti una potenza che non condivide i
nostri valori soprattutto quando si
parla di democrazia di libertà
individuali e di diritti umani
a un sistema economico che si pone in
alternativa a quello che è garantito la
nostra ricchezza
ha una potenza e possibilmente altre
potenze emergenti che potrebbero
decidere ancora di avanzare i propri
interessi sempre con l'uso della forza e
quindi terzo l'Europa
tutte le sfide di cui ho parlato sono
troppo grandi per un paese solo Ma negli
anni della crisi Il nostro rapporto con
l'Europa si è complicato particolarmente
sia per la gestione delle crisi passate
sia per la tendenza un po' più abusata
di rendere l'Unione Europea sempre un
capro espiatorio
ma nel mondo che vogliamo progettare e
la dimensione Europea quella che può
integrare a rappresentare tutti i nostri
valori e quindi abbiamo un interesse
primario nel far sì che lo sviluppo
dell'integrazione europea risponde in
maniera più chiara ai nostri bisogni
questo non vuol dire accettare o
assecondare qualunque progetto Purché
sia europeo ma impegnarci in maniera
critica facendo emergere una visione dal
territorio e fare emergere una visione
dal territorio significa anche
trasformare i nostri bisogni e le nostre
visioni in una domanda politica
e qui vengo al punto e questo riguarda
non solo me ma tutti noi dentro e fuori
il palco se noi per primi non siamo in
grado di definire con chiarezza Quali
sono i nostri bisogni anche che
importanza hanno per noi questi temi
globali Come possiamo aspettarci che i
governi La politica non si concentrano
su questioni di breve termine
soprattutto Dopo l'esplosione di
internet di social media la
comunicazione immediata anche cambiato
il tempo della politica a volte i
governi devono occuparsi di conseguenze
dei grandi temi per ragioni immediate e
hanno meno spazio per lavorare alle
cause profonde hanno meno opportunità di
farlo
ma kissinger ci ricordava una cosa
Quando è nato una crisi la passività non
fa altro che accrescere l'impotenza
e questa è la ragione per cui vi chiedo
aiuto
Io credo che per rispondere alle nostre
domande la dimensione migliore sia
quella delle comunità ma senza una presa
di coscienza individuale non si va da
nessuna parte è qualcosa che vedo
anch'io nel mio lavoro possiamo lavorare
quanto vogliamo sui grandi temi Ma se
alcune urgenze contingenti sostenute da
tutta la popolazione cambia nel nostro
Orizzonte dobbiamo cambiare anche il
nostro modo di valutare le nostre
decisioni di conseguenza
Aiutateci a riportare l'orizzonte in
avanti
Come possiamo farlo allora
partiamo da tre modi semplici primo
costruire e proteggete spazi di
confronto e di elaborazione parlate
nelle università nei circoli nelle
assemblee parlate nei partiti fatelo
online ma chiedetevi grandi domande Come
possiamo cambiare il nostro sistema
produttivo per mandare la barra per
mantenere la barra dritta sulla crisi
climatica quali valori e quali interessi
vogliamo proteggere Che ruolo ha per
esempio il commercio con un paese che
viene diritti umani o meglio dobbiamo
dare la priorità alla tutela
dell'agroalimentare o a recuperare
terreno sulla produzione di materiali
critici per la tecnologia di domani
secondo ordinate queste questioni
secondo quelle che hanno più valore
importanza per le vostre comunità Ora io
ho parlato di quelle che ritengo
fondamentali ma non c'è una lista
universale L'importante è che questo sia
fatto in maniera strutturata
approfondita e che abbia una conclusione
operativa e concreta
terzo terzo Anzi prendete queste
conclusioni E mettetele in mano ai
vostri referenti politici confrontatevi
invitatevi parlate con loro impegnati e
fate in modo che le conclusioni che
potete raggiungere insieme diventino
parte della loro comunicazione politica
e dei programmi di governo
Questo è un modo per ridurre la distanza
tra governanti e governati e quindi
migliorare la qualità della nostra
democrazia
al mio punto un altro e voglio
concludere da dove sono partito
fare questo offre una speranza a tutte
le persone che altrimenti andrebbero in
altri luoghi dove possono pensare di
sviluppare un'idea diversa di futuro
fare questo significa offrire una
speranza a quelle persone che come
quando si è aperta la mia crepa partono
da questa stazione per soddisfare un
bisogno per rispondere a un bisogno non
soltanto le loro aspirazioni
compiere queste azioni e rimettere tutti
questi tasselli nel nostro Orizzonte
significa dare una speranza a quella
persona significa dare una speranza alle
nostre comunità e poi Usarci a trovare
anche una speranza migliore per il
futuro grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]